On doit faire partie d'une communauté pour survivre.
On naît tellement démuni
que quelqu'un doit s'occuper de nous jusqu'à environ 10 ans,
et ainsi notre cerveau grandit en se nourrissant.
On a besoin d'être dans une communauté.
Donc que j'apprécie ou pas
de ne pas être invité au mariage de cet ami,
mon cerveau reptilien génère la même réponse
que si j'étais exclu de ma communauté.
La science explique plutôt bien pourquoi la justice est positive
et pourquoi l'injustice nous met sur la défensive,
mais la science montre aussi que dans une atmosphère de justice,
on ne veut pas seulement être le carré,
on a tendance à être le carré,
et ça permet aux autres gens d'être justes à leur tour.
Ça crée un beau cercle vertueux.
Mais si on entame la justice...
Une goutte d'injustice contamine la piscine entière,
et malheureusement, il y a beaucoup de gouttes dans cette piscine.
Donc on devrait s'efforcer d'éliminer
l'injustice autant que possible de partout,
en commençant par nos communautés et nos entreprises.
Je me soucie beaucoup de ça car je dirige une équipe de 3 000 personnes excellentes.
La différence entre 3 000 salariés heureux, motivés
et 3 000 autres qui regardent le temps passer, c'est énorme.
Donc la première chose que j'essaie de faire dans ma croisade pour la justice,
c'est de me sortir de l'équation.
C'est-à-dire être conscient de mes propres biais.
Par exemple, j'apprécie beaucoup les gens qui disent oui
à tout ce que je suggère.
(Rires)
Mais ce n'est pas très bon ni pour l'entreprise
ni pour tous ceux qui ont une opinion différente.
On essaie de promouvoir activement une culture de la diversité avec des opinions
et des personnalités différentes.
La deuxième chose est un peu plus procédurale.
On regarde l'ensemble des règles, des procédures, des systèmes de l'entreprise,
ceux qu'on utilise pour prendre des décisions, allouer des ressources
et on essaie de se débarrasser de tout ce qui n'est pas très clair,
ni rationnel, qui n'a pas de sens.
On essaie aussi de corriger tout ce qui limite
l'échange d'informations au sein de l'entreprise.
On analyse la culture et la motivation pour les mêmes raisons.
Mais je veux dire que même si on analyse sérieusement les règles,
les procédures, les systèmes - et il faut le faire -
mais indépendamment de ça,
on ne fera jamais assez pour atteindre la quintessence de la justice.
Parce que la dernière marche vers la justice demande quelque chose en plus,
qui a à voir avec les émotions des gens,
ce dont ils ont besoin,
ce qui se passe dans leurs vies privées,
ce dont la société a besoin.
Ce sont des questions et des éléments
qu'il est très difficile de faire rentrer dans un tableur ou un algorithme.
De les intégrer dans une décision rationnelle.
Mais si on les oublie, on manque des points clés
et le résultat risque d'être perçu comme injuste.
Donc on doit examiner nos décisions en faisant marcher notre sens de la justice.
Est-ce juste que cette personne obtienne le poste qu'elle espère vraiment avoir ?
ou que cette autre personne soit licenciée ?
ou qu'on facture autant pour ce produit ?
Ce sont des questions difficiles.
Mais si on prend le temps de se demander
si la réponse rationnelle est la réponse correcte...
On sait tous au fond de nous quelle est la réponse.
On le sait depuis notre plus jeune âge.
Et savoir quelle réponse est la bonne,
c'est plutôt bien pour prendre des décisions.
Et si on ouvre notre cœur,
c'est la clé pour tirer le meilleur des gens,
parce qu'ils peuvent sentir que vous y faites attention,
et c'est seulement comme ça qu'ils oublieront leurs peurs
et ils viendront travailler comme ils sont vraiment.
Si la justice est la clé de voûte dans la vie,
pourquoi chaque dirigeant n'en fait pas sa priorité ?
Ce ne serait pas génial de travailler dans une entreprise plus juste ?
et d'avoir des collègues et des chefs
sélectionnés, formés à la justice et selon leurs qualités morales
plutôt qu'avec des tests GMAT d'il y a 60 ans ?
Ce ne serait pas agréable de frapper à la porte
d'un responsable de la justice ?
On s'en rapproche, mais pourquoi ça n'arrive pas maintenant ?
En partie à cause de l'inertie,
en partie parce que ce n'est pas toujours facile d'être juste.
Ça réclame de juger et de prendre un risque.
Forer ce huitième puits était un risque.
Donner une promotion à celui qui n'avait pas fini le lycée aussi.
Construire une fromagerie en Équateur également.
Mais la justice est un risque à prendre,
donc on devrait se demander à nous-même,
où peut-on prendre ce risque ?
Où peut-on avancer un peu plus loin,
pour aller au-delà du rationnel et faire ce qui est juste ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)